No, this is not necessarily true. Look at these 2 people. They slept different
amounts of sleep, 6 hours and 8 hours but got the same temporal memory score
about 70.
Remember our discussion of lurking variables or extraneous factors? We haven't
taken all of these into account. In other words, we haven't controlled for
lurking variables. Sleep could influence memory, and by this trend, it looks
like it probably does. But, many other factors can also influence memory, and
this varies by person. There's a relationship here between hours slept and
temporal memory score, but that doesn't mean that hours slept causes a higher
temporal memory score. In other words, correlation does not prove causation.